le retour au pays c'est toujours quelque
chose sur lequel on a un peu de mal à
mettre des mots parce que c'est c'est
très intérieur et c'est très intime mais
c'est toujours un vrai bonheur que de
revenir ici à la martinique de retrouver
les sensations la chaleur les odeurs et
surtout les gens du pays parce que parce
que j'ai un vrai rapport est un vrai
beau rapport avec les gens de la
martinique alors avec un peu
d'appréhension parce que le cinéma c'est
un univers dans lequel je suis plongée
depuis maintenant deux ans mais que je
découvre je suis encore en apprentissage
donc c'est c'est une grosse
responsabilité
mais en même temps je suis très bien
accompagné entre
alain ingrid sébastien et puis et puis
olivier on a on fait vraiment très très
bon jury avec avec des compétences
diverses sur sur le regard qu'on peut
avoir sur le cinéma et puis des
sensibilités qui se rejoignent donc ça
fait quelque chose de très intéressant
comme comme jury oui ça je veux le dire
vraiment avec avec beaucoup de
d'engagement aujourd'hui il est de plus
en plus de canaux de diffusion et le
contenu la création c'est vraiment un
secteur qu'il va falloir investir de
plus en plus et c'est un secteur qui a
besoin de regard différent qui a besoin
de sensibilités différentes et c'est là
septembre dans lequel on peut vraiment
s'épanouir personnellement
donc voila moi j'engage tous ceux qui
sentent qu'ils ont des choses à dire
qu'ils ont envie de les dire et qui ont
envie de travailler à la fabrication de
ces choses-là de s'engager dans ces
métiers alors c'est pas facile mais
c'est facile nulle part il ya quand même
de l'avenir dans ces métiers de la
création
oui vraiment vraiment moi je suis très
fier parce que c'est un beau festival
c'est un beau jury et c'est ce sera un
beau palmarès parce qu'on avait une
superbe sélection
on a vraiment passé plusieurs heures
hier à regarder toutes ces oeuvres et à
aucun moment il ya eu de vrais baisse de
tension alors évidemment le niveau est
inégal parce que les moyens sont inégaux
parce que les expériences sont inégales
et savoir-faire le sont aussi il ya des
gens qui commencent qui apprennent ya
des gens qui sont un peu plus confirmé
mais y'a vraiment des choses superbes
est magnifique et moi j'ai vu parmi les
plus beaux pour métrage que j'ai jamais
vu je les ai vus à cette édition du prix
de court